Let's see,
we take your average person has no real unique personality.
Your traits,
their lives and decisions are based either on biological impulse or an
uncritical acceptance of social values.
The reactions are not unique.
The lath at weddings and cry at funerals all based on what is accepted in a
social context.
Their life has been shaped by immediate and an education system that does not
value individual expression and real examination Dubroski causes level one and a
significant majority of the population falls under this category.
Then on the other hand,
we have what he calls level five the visionaries,
the Nelson Mandela's and the Martin Luther kings at the world.
Nearly every action they take is in line with their core values and unique way
they see the world.
Truly visionary works are only created by people who were unrestrained and
social conviction,
deep strong acts of creative expression,
usually from action art or social change.
And then we have everyone else who is somewhere in between on both levels,
one to five.
There's a little internal conflict for level five that just because their
actions almost always aligned with their views online.
There was no internal turmoil because all decisions are based on,
well thought out hierarch go values on level one their actions are often self
advancement but they can always be justified either by a social norm like ice
speed because everyone else speeds or through the mindset of the ends justifies
the means and we see this all the time and leaders,
politicians,
it on TV shows like game of Thrones and house of cards at this level,
self advancement comes before all else.
This is something I saw a lot while I was working in sales.
There wasn't even a second thought given to misleading or misrepresenting the
truth in order to make a sale and it could always be justified by,
oh,
I have to hit my sales numbers in order to keep my job or something like,
Oh,
this guy drove up in a Rolls Royce.
He can afford it on level one because their values are shaped by culture.
They will only stay ethical as long as the society holds an ethical standard.
Where it gets interesting is between levels two through four.
This is where real personal struggle and existential crises begin to happen at
level two many of the status quo explanations for the way things are learned
through traditional education began to collapse under individual scrutiny.
They begin to see the gap between where the world could be in where it is right
now.
Common behaviors and ethics come to be seen as inadequate,
wrong or hypocritical.
Crises like these represent a strong potential for personal growth.
This person can now move ahead with careful examination of the world and their
own value system or the social and internal pressure can cause them to fall back
into level one.
Transitioning from level two to three you begin to compare and contrast actual
behavior.
Most people to a higher idealize choice.
Your authentic self will always choose the higher path is the clear and obvious
one to follow.
If this person's behavior fall short of the ideal.
There was internal disharmony in the are driven to review and reconstruct their
behavior to fit the ideal.
This is the point where you were like neo taking the red pill.
If you advance pass level three you can no longer go back to seeing the world
the way you used to.
It's a person does not have what Dobrosky calls enough developmental potential
to move past this point.
They will again fall back into level two and didn't level one
at level four a person takes full control of their development in voluntary
spontaneous reactions to stimulus or replaced by a conscious and self directed
view of life.
Old views of life are replaced by carefully thought out and examined ideals.
If a common social convention is seen as appropriate,
the person continues to accept it.
On the other hand is social norm can be reviewed and replaced by a self
perceived higher value.
One these individuals have a feeling of responsibility that extends to just
about everything.
This theory states that not all people have the potential to advance through all
five levels.
In fact,
most people will only get as far as level two unable to handle their existential
crisis.
They get integrated back into level one where they can seek comfort in the hive
mind or group.
Think Paradigm.
The most evident characteristic of people who have high developmental potential
is what he calls over excitability or how intensely that person experiences day
to day emotions.
The more over excitability a person has,
the more intensely they experience day to day life.
They feel the extreme highs and lows of joy and sorrow more profoundly.
There are often driven by their emotions and have a powerful perception of the
world.
They are more prone to experience an angst,
anxiety and depression,
and this is why his theory is called positive personality disintegration.
The more stress and turmoil a person is exposed to,
the more potential there personality has to develop.
The whole person on level five will face a little internal conflict.
Most likely they will experience a lot of resistance externally.
They do not care about how their actions are perceived by the outside world and
because of that,
they will probably face pressure to conform to society's standards.
Debraski says,
a person who's over excitability is high enough,
will undergo personality disintegration.
Despite any social or family efforts to stop it is can often place the person in
great peril with many brilliant minds ending up exiled,
assassinated,
or burnt at the stake
Dubroski called over excitability.
A tragic gift.
People who feel emotions more intensely are naturally going to experience great
highs and tragic lows.
They will face much internal and external conflict is their personality
develops.
The stress causes will drive personal growth,
but can actually result in suicide from people who can't handle their world
being turned upside down.
People with high potential for development have to walk their own path often at
the expense of fitting in.
Joseph Campbell said in nights quest for the grail.
If a path exists in the forest,
don't follow it for though it took someone else to the grill.
It will not take you because it is not here.